then I would have three four three focus
on the arena and I would have three four
three focus on free uh focus on whatever
that Battle Royale that's going on right
now uh you know really make sure that
that comes out as best as it can
obviously they're going to keep battle
passes and stuff like that and I would
rotate the the multiplayer function
behind Arena
and Battle Royale because I do think
there is a point where
I don't think the name of Halo's
downgrading I think the competition is
upgrading you didn't have fortnite's
rolling wild back then you didn't have
Apex Legends run wild back then like
and and and I think that
you can't compete with that without a
free-to-play battle royale game you just
can't look at look how long fortnite has
thought or still stood around and they
don't seem to be slowing down Apex
Legend has been